are the galaxy book pros the best
all-around ultrabooks to buy
well when i first saw the announcement i
thought it was going to be underpowered
it's going to run hot and loud
but once we actually used and compare
them i was really surprised
especially by three different things and
know that it's not including
the oled displays and overall i just
have one complaint about this machine
that may or may not be a deal breaker
for you
now let's start out by mentioning that i
have two of these models obviously you
guys can see i have a 13
inch and a 15 inch model these are both
i7
models and between them the performance
is almost identical which is a great
thing
samsung is keeping it very simple with
these machines you just have a few
choices you want a 13 13-inch or a
15-inch
and do you want the base model that has
256 gigs of ssd
and an ia5 cpu or do you want to upgrade
that to get double the storage and
double
the ram and that is great other than
that
the screens are both oled displays and
they are both 1920 by 1080p
and they are both pros and cons with
that screen
but before we dive into performance and
everything else let me give a thank you
to microcenter for sponsoring this video
micro center has 25 stores nationwide
with an impressive variety of
electronics
from gaming vr computer parts like
processors graphics
and everything else needed to build a pc
they also have a huge variety of
desktops laptops and all the accessories
that you need
not only that but they also have highly
trained staff and low prices
check out our local micro center today
to get your hands on a variety of
products before purchasing
or use the link down below to check out
these galaxy book pros
at microcenter.com let's start out with
the design and build quality
i have to say that this 13 inch is
impossibly
lightweight feeling in the hand i know
we've reviewed the lg gram and that
thing is light
but this thing takes it to a whole
nother level it comes in at 1.9
pounds and it is very very slim
a lot slimmer than the other laptops the
gram is thicker
the xps is a lot thicker you guys can
see there's even cutouts
for the hdmi to allow it to fit and then
the same thing for the usb port on
the other side now as far as ports both
these machines are identical
we have an hdmi a usb type-c and a
thunderbolt port and this does charge
with usb type-c
and on the other side we have a micro sd
card slot a full-size usb type-a which
is crazy
and then a headphone jack now the larger
15-inch model
this thing comes in at an unbelievable
2.3 pounds so although it is heavier the
weight's a little bit further from your
hand
it is still insanely light for a 15-inch
machine
and with that the build quality is
surprisingly good
for that weight we have a magnesium
alloy shell and even though it's so
thin and so light it has very little
flex a lot less flex
than that lg graham now there is one
difference
with the 15 inch model you can flex a
little bit more and actually get the key
the little click pad to click by flexing
it
that doesn't happen with the 13 inch
just because it's a little bit more
dense so this one does feel a little bit
better as far as
the overall stiffness of the chassis but
i have no complaints with either one
one thing that is slightly annoying is
just how much of a fingerprint magnet
these machines are both the outside
where i have the blue and then
even the palm area right over here so
keep that in mind you're gonna have to
clean them up getting into the quality
of the keyboards and the track pads we
do have a fingerprint scanner built in
so right there very easy unfortunately
the webcam
does not have windows hello unlock which
that's a bummer i love being able to
just open it up and log in
on some of the other windows laptops the
keyboard itself on the larger model we
have this numpad
and the quality is great has a nice feel
to it
a lot of feedback it's fairly quiet the
track pad on the other hand
it's just about average it's a lot
harder to click up top
almost impossible here a lot easier like
a standard diving board design
it is fairly responsive and gestures do
work well now the other thing that's
about average
with these laptops are the webcams
and the microphones they're not bad but
they're not particularly good
go ahead and take a listen this is the
microphone quality of the galaxy book
pro's dual front-facing microphones and
this is the video quality you can expect
with the highest settings and now let's
get into
probably the biggest spec sheet item for
these laptops especially at the price
and that is the displays we have
two oled panels on both of these which
is really rare for a laptop
at this price point especially rare for
a laptop that is
this thin and lightweight now oled
allows you to have
uh each pixel that can turn off on its
own and that allows for
perfect contrast where video looks
excellent on there
and that definitely is true for these
laptops if you're watching in a dark
environment then video looks excellent
provides a great movie
experience but unfortunately if you're
not watching in a pure
dark room if you're an environment like
this or especially if you're
outside the benefit of oled gets lost
because of reflectivity now when you're
outside
the screens do get quite bright 400 nits
that's better than
average but it's still not enough to
battle that
uh how easily the the screen reflects so
that can be an issue and unfortunately
samsung didn't put on
a you know top of the line coding like
some of the new dell xps are using
now along with that the displays are not
touch screen
so if you're into that if you like being
productive you like scrolling be able to
select things
you're not able to do that with the
screen and the display is also a 1080p
resolution on both of these now that is
both a plus and a minus on the minus
side
if you are watching movies if you select
4k
you're not going to get that full
benefit of that sharp image
and when you're reading text if you're
doing spreadsheets being productive
you can tell the difference you can tell
that it's not as sharp as
other offerings especially on the 15
inch model on the plus side we have
battery life which i might as well just
mention
right now it is excellent it was
definitely
a nice surprise um about 10 to 12 hours
on the smaller one and about 9 to 11
hours with the larger 15 inch which is
an
excellent battery life for the a15 inch
in part because
it is using a mobile chip one of the
ones designed for ultrabooks
not a higher end i7 and the display
being 1920x1080
that saves battery plus the oled helps
as well now the last thing i want to
cover
as far as the screens is the aspect
ratio
you guys can see that it's wider 16 by
nine
a lot of laptops are using 16 by 10 now
gives you a little bit of extra vertical
space
it's not as big of a deal for this
15-inch model as the 13-inch
where it really helps and then some
laptops use 3x2 which is really great
for spreadsheets and other productivity
and now
let's talk about speakers this is really
my biggest disappointment with these
machines
the speakers sound decent not great
probably about
average just like the trackpad is
average and the webcams are average
in terms of windows laptops but if you
are gonna enjoy this ola display to
watch movies or shows
at night or even maybe play some games
and you don't have headphones to use
it is fairly quiet one of the quieter
laptops that we have tested within the
last couple years
so keep that in mind if speakers are
important to you for movies or anything
else
you probably aren't going to be very
thrilled with these speakers and now
let's get into the second way how these
really stand out and that is the
performance when i first saw these
machines and how lightweight and thin
they were
i said surely one the performance is
gonna be suffering
because of thermal throttling the fan
noise is gonna be loud
and with that most likely when you
unplug it in order to reach that battery
life the performance is going to plummet
but i was really pleasantly surprised
both of these right here are i7s the i5s
are not that much slower
and in single core both get around 1500
a little bit higher than 1500 which is
excellent with these 11 gen processors
and multi-core of over
5 000 and with that fan noise
wasn't really that much of an issue sure
you can hear it but
it wasn't very loud and the temps were
good as well so i don't know what
voodoo magic samsung did with these
machines to make them run
so nicely compared to other laptops that
are thicker using the same processors
but they did a good job but what
surprised me absolutely the most
is the performance when you unplug it
the performance basically
does not change we saw other laptops
that get cut
by about half to a third in performance
these almost didn't change and so what
does that mean in the real world well
with this good battery life and the
performance that stays the same you
don't have to worry about finding
somewhere to plug it in
now for our photoshop test the new super
resolution tool
it actually upsized a 42 megapixel raw
image in 53
seconds unplugged whereas our
lg that we tested which slows down
dramatically
when it's unplugged that got close to 10
minutes
now of course it's not as fast as an m1
macbook air which we also
tested that does in 13 seconds but
that's dedicated machine learning cores
with the m1 chip so overall unplug
performance is
great now the same thing goes with
graphics the
intel iris xe graphics in here they
perform great using vulkan and geekbench
five we have around 16
000 also does not go down at all when
you unplug it so what does that cpu and
gp performance really mean in the real
world
well in adobe lightroom the same exact
export 42 megapixel raw images 50 of
them that are edited
took four minutes and one second for the
galaxy note pro compared to four minutes
and 25 seconds
for our m1 macbook air and that
software is actually the apple silicon
version and the editing is
just as smooth as with the m1 macbook
air so i definitely was not
expecting that now in video editing it
is just as fast as the dell xps even
though it is cheaper
and there it does go a little bit slower
than i am on macbook air but it does not
have those special encoding chips that
the m1 does
and the last thing that i want to talk
about that really surprised me
is just the price point i saw the 999
price point for the base 13 inch model
this one comes in at 200 more and the
10.99 for the 15 inch model this one
also is the upgraded one
that is just a great price if you're
comparing it to the lg gram to the dell
xps to the huawei
you know to a lot of other windows
laptops out there not only does it
perform
better especially unplugged the fans are
quieter
we have more ports the quality is good
it is
lighter but the price point comes in at
about 200
less than the competition and of course
you have this ola display
if you're going to use it in darker
environments you get that benefit
as well so when you combine all of that
and you know that you need a windows
laptop
these are great options of course you're
going to miss a couple things such as
maybe a brighter and less reflective
display
or the ability to swap out your ssd you
know things like that
but when you factor in the price point
and what you get they definitely
are a great value now of course i have
to also mention
the m1 macbooks especially the m1
macbook air
that thing comes in at the same msrp you
can also get it on sale
and it does have a display that is just
as bright but it's less reflective
and it is more color accurate has a
better keyboard and trackpad
better speakers and also better
performance but that does run mac os and
even though we love mac os
a lot of people they can't yet use it uh
they maybe they need windows or maybe
they just prefer windows and not having
to go through parallels
stuff stuff like that so i definitely
see the reason for having these in the
market so samsung
you guys did a killer job you're keeping
it simple great price points
great design and quality and insanely
lightweight
while still managing good performance
and good battery life
even when it's unplugged so there you
guys have it that is my review
if you're looking for a great machine
this would be definitely at the top of
my list for windows laptops once again
we have links to micro center down below
you guys can click that circle above if
you guys want to subscribe and help us
reach our goal of 1 million subscribers
before the end of the year
you guys can check out one of those
great videos over there this is max and
i will see you
in the next video